WELCOME BACK TO "THE BIG
SATURDAY SHOW".
IT IS TIME NOW FOR THE BIG
SATURDAY FLOPS.
WE ARE NOT JUST TALK ABOUT THE
ALABAMA STORE.
TIX FOR THE BIGGEST FAILS OF THE
WEEK.
MY PICK IS THE BIGGEST LOSERS
FOR THE MIDTERMS THIS IS STACEY
ABRAMS AND ROBERT FRANCIS BETO
O'ROURKE.
JUST DO NOT TELL MSNBC WHO IS
COMPARING ABRAMS TO MOSES.
>> NEVER SEEN ANYBODY WITH THE
STATE WIRED LIKE STACEY ABRAMS
FOR HER SHE MAY HAVE LOST, SHE
LOST WE UNDERSTAND THAT.
TALK ABOUT HOW SHE PUT GEORGE ON
THE MAP.
>> HE DID NOT GET THERE HIMSELF.
GOD TOOK CARE OF MOSES.
YOU ALL LEAVE MOSES ALONE.
AND LET JOSHUA KEEP GOING.
AND STACY WILL GET HER TO DO GOD
REWARD STACY.
>> AARON SAID I'M NOT
TRANSLATING THAT STUFF.
HERE IS THE DEAL ABOUT ALL OF
THIS FOR I LIVE IN GEORGIA AT
STACEY ABRAMS WAS NEVER EVER
GOING TO BE THE GOVERNOR OF
GEORGIA FOR DEMOCRATS MAY WIN
BUT NOT WITH HER.
THEY DO NOT TRUST OR THEY DO NOT
TRUST HER.
AND BETO, LORD HELP THAT FELLOW.
PENNSYLVANIA STATE
REPRESENTATIVE IS REELECTED BY A
LANDSLIDE EVEN THOUGH HE IS
DEAD.
THERE HAS TO BE A SPECIAL
ELECTION, GUYS WE ARE ALL
WANTING WHAT DHEC HAPPENED IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THIS GIVES US A LITTLE MORE
EVIDENCE MAYBE SOMETHING IS NOT
ALL RIGHT THERE.
DEMOCRAT ANTHONY TONY DELUCA WON
STATE REPRESENTATIVE RAISED BY A
LANDSLIDE DESPITE THE FACT HE
DIED ABOUT A MONTH AGO.
VERY INTERESTING THINGS
HAPPENING.
THIS IS SOMEWHAT OF AN
IMPROVEMENT.
I'LL USUALLY DEAD PEOPLE ARE
ONLY ALLOWED TO VOTE AND NOW
THEY GET TO RUN FOR OFFICE.
>> IT'S ALL COMING FULL CIRCLE
OR CLICKS TO MY POINT EARLIER WE
ARE LOWERING THE BAR WE REALLY
ARE.
>> NUMBER ONE PROGRESS WE COULD
ELECT ONLY DEAD PEOPLE TO
CONGRESS FOR JUST TWO YEARS IT
WOULD PROBABLY FIX LIKE MOST OF
THE PROBLEMS IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> FROM STACEY ABRAMS BEING
MOSES I'M SCOOTING MY CHURCH OF
THE LEFT, LIGHTNING IS COMING TO
THE CEILING.
>> ARE ABOUT TO GET IN TROUBLE
OR MSNBC IF THAT WAS NOT ENOUGH
WONDERS OF JOHN FETTERMAN WILL
RUN FOR THE WHITE HOUSE IN 2024
THEY ARE NOT KIDDING ACTUALLY.
>> IS A NOMINEE AT SOME POINT
FOR PRESIDENT.
I NOTICED THERE ARE SOME
VARIABLES OBVIOUSLY.
WHAT HE DID IN THE SUPER RED
DEEP RED PARTS OF PENNSYLVANIA
AND THE WAY HE RAN AHEAD OF
BIDEN HE RAN AHEAD OF TRUMP.
IT MAKES YOU WONDER ABOUT HIS
FUTURE.
[LAUGHTER]
CLUSTERS RD A BUMPER STICKER
THERE IT SAYS BIDEN/FETTERMAN
NO-BRAINER.
[LAUGHTER]
I WAS SEXUAL KIND OF SERIOUS
ABOUT THIS.
AFTER THE DEBATES I WAS
CONVINCED THAT ACTION MIGHT BE
HELP HIM.
I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE LOOK AT
JOHN FETTERMAN AND THEY THINK HE
CAN'T GET A JOB ANYWHERE ELSE,
WHAT SENT HIM TO WASHINGTON FOR.
>> SERIOUSLY THAT'S WHAT THEY
THINK?
>> THAT'S THE LEVEL OF THEIR
CONTEMPT FOR CONGRESS.
>> THEY DID NOT EXPECT THEM TO
ANSWER IN DETAIL ON THE
QUESTIONS I THINK IT DID
ACTUALLY HELP THEM THAT WAY.
>> I DO NOT KNOW.
LET THE DAMNATION OF CONGRESS OF
NOTHING ELSE FOR.
>> IT CERTAINLY IS MEANTIME IF
YOU'RE STRESSED OUT ON ELECTION
NIGHT THE NEW YORK TIME HAS SOME
ODD ADVICE FOR THAT READERS WHO
ARE COPING WITH THAT ELECTION
STRESS.
THE NEWSPAPER RELEASED A FIVE
STEP GUIDE AS THE POLLS CLOSE ON
TUESDAY THE FIVE STEP TO TRY
FIVE FINGER BREATHING, COOLDOWN,
MOVE, BREATHE LIKE A BABY, LIMIT
YOUR SCROLLING, MEET MY RESPONSE
AND YOUR TIMES AS IF WE ALL
LIVED IN FLORIDA AND COUNTED OUR
BALLOTS THE WAY THEY DID
EFFICIENTLY AND YOU WANT LIKE
RON DESANTIS BITE 19 POINTS YOU
WOULD NOT BE STRESSED OUT.
>> .STRESSED ABOUT LIVING TO
FIVE FINGER DEATH APPROACH IS A
GREAT BAND.
COARSE NOT BREATHING LIKE A BABE
RUTH OUT THAT'S ALWAYS WHAT
LIBERAL DOES BUT MAYBE I'M WRONG
FOR THAT THE NEW TECHNIQUE.
>> NOT TO BE MEAN IF YOU NEED
YOUR FIVE FINGERS TO COUNT FIVE
FINGER BREATHING YOU EITHER HAVE
ANOTHER PROBLEM WE ARE COUNTING
VOTES.
>> ONLY GET FOUR AND A HALF.
THAT'S WHY STAY STRESSED OUT
FREQUENCIES OR "NEW YORK TIMES"
READERS.
WE WISH THEM THE BEST.
THAT'S GOING TO DO IT FOR US.
IT HAS BEEN SELF AND AS ALWAYS
BEING HERE WITH YOU GUYS.
WE